[Music]
welcome to this video where we will
discuss database options for gke users
we'll cover what your options are and
focus on two managed databases
Cloud SQL and Cloud spanner and see
whether these might be right for your
cluster requirements
before we continue you should already be
familiar with what stateless and
stateful applications are
as well as the differences between
relational and non-relational databases
now there are different types of
workloads you can run in gke including
stateless and stateful applications
if you are using stateful applications
in your cluster then you'll need a
database as these apps need to store
data
let's review the options you have for
running a database on the Google Cloud
platform
you could opt for a self-managed
database
a database on gke itself
or a fully managed database
in this video we'll focus on fully
managed databases
compared with the other two options this
type of database requires the least
effort from you to operate and manage
you just need to create a database build
your app and Google Cloud takes care of
the rest installation upgrade storage as
well as many of the maintenance tasks
like backups and scaling
this option makes it a lot easier to
deploy and scale your database servers
Cloud provides several database options
to cover all database use cases
from relational to non-relational
database needs and even in memory
each database has its own features and
the type you'll need depends on your
specific use case
if you are looking for a database option
for your gke clusters Cloud SQL and
Cloud spanner are great choices
using a fully managed database server
outside your gke cluster can make your
applications more highly available
and allows for more complex scenarios
like having your app spread across
multiple clusters
both Cloud SQL and spanner are fully
managed services with a high level of
availability scalability and performance
so how do you know which database fits
your needs better
let's take a look at two fictitious
organizations
easy shop is a finish-based e-commerce
company using gke to host the services
they build
they want to migrate their thousands of
databases from their on-prem data
centers to Google cloud with minimal
downtime and want to easily connect to
the database from gke
their developers are familiar with
postgres SQL so easy shop would prefer a
managed database that is compatible with
this system
Game Wizards is a company that uses gke
to build games for them data integrity
and availability are critical needs for
a database
they don't want to spend too much time
on Administration or scalability issues
rather they prefer to focus on game
development and user experience
game results is launching a new game
shortly and anticipates a huge increase
in player base across the globe over the
next few months so they are looking for
a database that can handle massive
amounts of data with extremely low
latency
Cloud SQL is a good choice for easy shop
as it provides a fully managed
environment for specific database
engines including postgresql
it's the more cost effective choice for
an organization that requires a high
level of availability and performance
but doesn't need to scale Beyond a
single region
on the other hand Cloud spanner is a
good fit for Game Wizards
they need a globally distributed
relational database that can handle
large amounts of data for a successful
Game launch with spanner there is no
fixed size limit so it can grow as the
business grows
you can see from these examples how
Cloud SQL and spanner can serve
different business needs
spanner is unique as it has the benefits
of relational databases with the
horizontal scalability you would
normally expect from a non-relational
database
it's best suited for apps such as gaming
retail banking Payment Solutions any
large-scale Global applications where
you require unlimited scalability and
strong consistency
Cloud SQL is more suited for smaller
scale database requirements such as
general purpose web Frameworks
e-commerce apps and so on
whichever platform you choose though
both database options offer easy
integration with gke
first you'll set up a database instance
and create the database
then you'll set up a service account
that will be used by gke to connect to
the database of your choice
once you deploy your applications in the
gke cluster they will connect to the
database instance
using a fully managed database in Google
Cloud simplifies the process of
provisioning and maintaining the
database and frees up your resources so
you can focus on building your
applications
for more detailed steps on how to
connect your gke applications to either
Cloud SQL or Cloud spanner check out our
documentation thanks for watching
[Music]